Spuren
einer Ehe
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht zuerst hat er mir ins
Gesicht gestochen so von hier nach da
ich habe versucht mich zu schützen dann
hat er das Messer in meiner Hand
gestochen
zweimal dreimal es waren drei Mal als
ich das ganze Blut gesehen habe hatte
ich solche Angst
drei Monate ist das jetzt her Melek lebt
wieder bei den Eltern zeigt ihrer
Familie zum ersten mal was ihr Mann ihr
angetan hat
ich kann mich sehr glücklich schützen
dass meine Eltern hinter mir stehen denn
im Frauenhaus habe ich viele Frauen
kennengelernt keiner dieser Frauen hat
Unterstützung sie haben keine
Schulbildung sie kennen ihr Recht nicht
und so erleben Sie regelmäßig Gewalt
werden vergewaltigt und misshandelt
ihr Recht ist das Gesetz
6284 nur deshalb konnte Melek sofort mit
den Kindern ins Frauenhaus wurde sofort
eine einstweilige Verfügung gegen den
Ehemann erlassen konnte sie sofort die
Scheidung einreichen das Gesetz ist das
schärfste Schwert im Kampf gegen Gewalt
an Frauen noch denn es könnte Erdogans
Wahlkampf zum Opfer fallen und gekippt
werden
das Gesetz
6.284 ist ein schnellgreifendes Werkzeug
es funktioniert als einstweilige
Verfügung wenn eine Frau Gewalt
ausgesetzt ist oder die Gefahr auf
Gewalt besteht können wir die
Staatsanwaltschaft und Polizei sehr
schnell nämlich innerhalb von 24 Stunden
diese einstweilige Verfügung erhalten
und gleichzeitig müssen wir keine
Beweise für die Gewalt vorlegen
für Erdogan und seine Gattin braucht es
dafür keine Gesetze das sei Ehrensache
wir sind gegen Gewalt gegen Frauen
Gewalt gegen Frauen ist Verrat an der
Menschheit und mit dieser
Selbstverständlichkeit verkündet der
Präsident vor zwei Jahren den Austritt
aus dem internationalen Abkommen zum
Schutz für Frauen der
istanbul-konvention das Abkommen sieht
der Präsident als ein Angriff vom Westen
auf die traditionelle türkische Familie
im Westen zerbrechen die Familien weil
die Frauen von ihren Familien entfremdet
werden und nun versuchen Sie uns dieses
Spiel ebenfalls aufzuzwingen
im Wahlkampf haben Erdogans neue
Verbündete dem Präsidenten nun auch noch
das Einverständnis abgerungen das Gesetz
6.284 zu verändern die kurdisch
islamistische hühnerpaar etwa findet das
Gesetz Stifte die Frau zur Lüge an
Erklärung durch deren Frauen beauftragte
mit der Stärkung der Frau wird der Mann
isoliert denn was sagt das Gesetz
die Darstellung einer Frau ist immer
wahr alles was die Frau sagt stimmt die
Frau hat bedingungslos Recht das
bedeutet aber auch dass bei jeder
kleinsten Auseinandersetzung in der
Familie die Frau behaupten kann dass ihr
Mann gewalttätig wurde und somit wird
sie zur Lüge verleitet
auch diejenigen referpartei mit dem
erklärten Ziel die Islamisierung im Land
voranzutreiben will das Gesetz so nicht
länger angewendet Wissen Erläuterung
durch den Anwalt der Partei
natürlich wollen wir sicherstellen dass
Frauen und Kinder geschützt werden aber
ohne dass dabei die Institution Familie
beschädigt wird
er sagt er wolle auch die Männer
schützen vor Frauen die das Gesetz
missbrauchen
vor dem Gesetz gilt doch dass jeder
unschuldig ist bis die Schuld bewiesen
ist wenn sie behaupten dass ich mir was
zu Schulden habe kommen lassen dann
müssen sie mir das beweisen
doch eine solche Beweispflicht dauert
in dem langen Prozess bis zum Urteil ist
die Frau nicht geschützt diese Änderung
kommt einem Wegfall des
6.284er gesetzesgleich das bedeutet die
Frau steht vor verschlossenen Tür
ein solcher Prozess bedeutet Zeit die
Melek nicht hatte ohne das Gesetz wäre
sie gestorben da ist sich die 25-Jährige
sicher
er drohte mich umzubringen er wolle mir
eine Lektion erteilen er werde mein
Gesicht verätzt nur mich vor das Haus an
einem Seil aufhängen damit mich alle
sehen können
niemand habe das Recht sie anzuzweifeln
in einer solchen Lage findet sie
ich will nicht erst beweisen müssen dass
ich misshandelt wurde bevor was getan
wird ich möchte dass sie mich als Frau
schützen ich will dass meine Stimme
gehört wird
[Musik]
ihm ist wütend jeden Tag sterbe in der
Türkei mindestens eine Frau durch
häusliche Gewalt doch die Täter blieben
zu oft straflos seit 13 Jahren kämpfe
ihr Verein gegen diese Ungerechtigkeit
wir haben ein ein mann-regime alle Macht
ist konzentriert in den Händen eines
Mannes er allein kann Dekrete erlassen
und ein neues Bündnis mit Männern Formen
und die wollen Frauen die
fortgeschritten sind die modern sind die
ihr eigenes Leben haben unter Druck
setzen und kontrollieren
die Staatsanwaltschaft will ihren Verein
verbieten lassen er sei
familienfeindlich doch Fiedern wird
weitermachen gerade jetzt kurz vor der
Wahl denn es gehe längst um mehr wenn
wir diese Regierung nicht abwählen dann
stehen uns sehr dunkle Zeiten bevor was
wir tun werden wenn sie an der Macht
bleiben weiter kämpfen nicht einen
Schritt zurückweichen
[Musik]
bei seinen Veranstaltungen besteht der
Präsident auf Geschlechtertrennung
fordert Familien auf mindestens drei
Kinder zu bekommen propagiert das
Kopftuch und Erdogans neue Verbündete
gehen noch weiter die kurdisch
islamistische hydar etwa will den Schutz
der traditionellen Familie vor
abweichenden Ideologien durchsetzen
Mädchen und Jungen getrennt unterrichten
und Frauen Arbeitsbedingungen anbieten
die ihrer Natur entsprechen die
islamistische Partei jeniden REFA macht
unterdessen Wahlwerbung mit einem Bus
auf dem männliche Parlamentskandidaten
mit Bild gezeigt werden von der
weiblichen Kandidatin hingegen nur ein
Schatten ein Ausrutscher ein Einzelfall
sagt Anwalt Yilmaz seine Frau sei
berufstätig und gleichzeitig der
Grundpfeiler der Familie
die Frau ist gleich Familie es ist die
Frau die die Familie am Leben hält es
ist die Frau die den Haushalt meist für
die Kinder sorgt und für ihren man da
ist ich bin ein Mann aber wenn meine
Frau nicht dieses Hemd bügelt und mir
mein Einstecktuch hier anbringt dann
kann ich nicht aus dem Haus zur selben
Zeit bin ich in der bringen Schuld meine
Frau glücklich zu machen und sie muss
mich glücklich machen nur so kann ich
mit einem Lächeln aus dem Haus und
nützlich für die Gesellschaft sein
viele Frauen sehen das anders eine
internationale Studie attestiert dem
Land das 60% der Frauen unglücklich sein
in der Türkei sogar mehr als 80% der
Frauen fühlten sich abends auf der
Straße nicht sicher als wichtigstes
Problem nennen drei von vier sexuelle
Belästigung und Gewalt gegen Frauen sie
ist eine von ihm wir nennen sie Eiche
ihr Gesicht zeigen will sie nicht aus
Angst vor ihrem Stalker es ist ihr
Cousin
er konnte meinen nein nicht akzeptieren
er hatte das Gefühl ich bin ein Mann und
darf nicht abgewiesen werden er wurde
immer wütender er fing an zu drohen du
musst bei mir sein wenn nicht dann töte
ich dich es ist besser wenn du stirbst
[Musik]
anderthalb Jahre geht das nun so doch
als sie endlich den Mut fasst und zur
Polizei geht wimmelt der Beamte sie ab
ich schicke dir zwar er hat mich gefragt
ob Gewalt im Spiel ist worauf ich dann
antwortete ob man erst getötet werden
muss damit Auflagen greifen und da ich
dachte dass eh nichts passieren wird
habe ich auf einer Anzeige verzichtet
ein Frauenverein hat sie motiviert nicht
aufzugeben kurz vor der Wahl wollen Sie
noch einmal das Gesetz
6284 berufen denn alle hier fürchten was
nach der Wahl passieren könnte
sollte Erdogan gewinnen haben wir Angst
ich weiß wie sich das anfühlt und jede
von uns könnte betroffen sein wir hoffen
auf kölsch-star Rollo darauf dass er zu
uns Frauen steht
musst
[Musik]
der Kandidat der Opposition hatte
bereits angekündigt dass er sollte er
gewinnen dafür sorgen werde dass ich die
Türkei wieder zum Schutz der Frauen
bekennt so geht es bei dieser Wahl für
viele Betroffene türkische Frauen um
mehr als um einen
Präsidentschaftskandidaten es geht um
Ihren persönlichen Schutz